Hi there. I'm Lenore Flower and I am here to Sherpa you through introduction to
preparing and modeling data with Power BI or as I like to think of it, data plumbing.
Data modeling is a lot like plumbing.
They're both about building the foundation for other key things to work well.
In this course, we'll be learning how to
connect up everything we need for a good data pipeline,
and just like plumbing, none of
your reporting end users are going to know anything about it when it's working.
But they'll definitely notice when it's not.
I like to think of preparing and modeling as the unsung hero in Power BI
since it tends to get a little less attention than
its more glamorous data visualization layer.
Don't get me wrong. Storytelling with data is awesome and absolutely important,
but without all the plumbing and prep work underneath,
none of those stories would be possible.
I was an early adopter of Power BI at my organization where at the time I
was looking for ways to better
present corporate reporting information as a financial analyst.
I quickly became fascinated with how you could mash
different data sources together and how learning just enough of some
of the key technologies such as Power Query and DAX could
set you up to create more complex and powerful analytics when you needed them.
As I continued to explore various data sources to enrich my analysis,
I realized that Power BI is broadly applicable beyond finance, and to my delight,
I also learned that the same technologies I use to
transform and model data in Power BI are
equally applicable to Excel and even scale up
to the enterprise level through Azure tabular data models,
which is my primary focus today.
While our focus will be on Power BI,
a lot of the key concepts I'm going to teach you in this course will
also apply to many other data modeling tools.
I love that data modeling is scalable as well as flexible
and it can be a lot of fun to collaborate with colleagues to solve their challenges.
At my day job managing enterprise-level data models,
I get to work with a pretty wide web of people to understand
what data is needed and how we can get the data plumbing
right to enable analysis of
seemingly unrelated information or make it difficult to compile reports automatic.
Well, I'm not always in the limelight showing off dashboards at company meetings,
I find it incredibly rewarding to create the foundations for
beautiful and efficient reports that my colleagues
know they can rely on for accurate information.
Knowing the principles of data modeling also positions me to play superhero for
my colleagues when they get stuck on
a Power BI reporting problem and need a nudge in the right direction.
I'm excited to get you started working on preparing and modeling data in Power BI.
My goal is to give you a strong foundation in the key concepts,
many of which will allow you to not only use
Power BI more effectively but will also give you
the data modeling tools that you'll be able to apply in
tackling a huge range of different problems with confidence.
Sometimes a little help from Google in your future role as data superhero and plumber.